je rappelle qu aura une primaire à
gauche le 22 et 29 janvier donc c'est ça
le moyen démocratique et apaisé de
pouvoir désigner le candidat soit
candidat pour pouvoir s'exprimer
moi je ne je ne le souhaite ni je ne je
ne souhaite pas ou jeu mais je n'ai pas
non plus à nous c'est à lui d'en décider
si vous voulez qu'ils le fassent au kid
le fan qui ne le fasse pas pour moi la
question françois hollande appartient
maintenant au passé alors je vraiment
l'aveyron que je considère partir
françois hollande appartient au passé et
maintenant la gauche doit tourner une
nouvelle page et cette nouvelle page
elle doit commencer avec la primaire de
la gauche